eleven times wider than Earth
over 300 times more massive
and a million times more terrifying
Jupiter looks like a beautiful ball of
swirling clouds but on the inside it's a
gaseous hell
what if things took a different turn for
the king of the solar system what if
Jupiter wasn't the gas giant at all
What If instead it was a rock Giant
what would its surface be like
what could make this world habitable and
what would happen if you tried to walk
on it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter was a rocky planet
Jupiter is old like four and a half
billion years old
it started as a swirling disc of gas and
dust that formed into a pretty big
planetary core
with time Jupiter's core grew attracting
more and more rock ice and Metal
but Jupiter wasn't going to become a
rocky planet now it had an enormous
appetite for gas yeah Jupiter's powerful
gravitational pull Drew in massive
amounts of hydrogen and helium that
shaped it into the Majestic gas giant we
see today
but what if things went differently
you know what if
What If instead of gas Jupiter kept
pulling in more Rocky materials until it
became the most massive terrestrial
world in the solar system
would that be the end for everything in
our planetary neighborhood
just like our Cosmic Journeys and
what-if videos you can embark on a mind
Journey that's both free and accessible
you can do it with our sponsor brilliant
if you love what if you're gonna love
brilliant it uses interactive Hands-On
learning to explore topics like math
data science and computer science it's
for people like you curious explorers
who want to sharpen their skills and
even help get a career boost what I like
about brilliant is how it tailors The
Learning Experience to my level in Pace
I've recently been enjoying their course
on astrophysics and at times it feels
like one of our videos a thrilling
Expedition into the complexities of the
cosmos but it always feels accessible
and approachable so give brilliant a
shot you can start your Learning Journey
for the first 30 days completely free
and you get 20 off by going to
brilliant.org what if Link in the
description
for this Jupiter apocalypse we'll keep
Jupiter's size just as it is today only
now all rock no gas
Jupiter would become unimaginably
massive
this world would be four times heavier
than its gas giant form and keep in mind
the gas giant Jupiter is already about
twice as massive as all the other
planets in the solar system combined
and with this enormous Mass would come
unimaginably strong gravity
Rocky Jupiter's gravitational pull would
now be four times more powerful than it
was before and that's about 10 times
stronger than the gravity you and I live
with here on Earth
yeah you wouldn't be able to walk on
this Rocky Jupiter your body would
experience a gravitational pull so
extreme that it would break your bones
your heart would beat out of your chest
working so hard to pump your blood and
as your blood pooled in your lower body
you'd feel dizzy and lightheaded
well you may not want to walk on this
Jupiter anyway the rocky King of the
solar system would now attract even more
moons and asteroids and some of them
would be on a collision course with the
rocky Giant
but what would its surface be like
anyway
well apart from the constant asteroid
collisions it could be a pretty nice
place to visit if you could walk there
of course
Rocky Jupiter would still lie outside
the Solar System's habitable zone but
this doesn't mean it would be a frigid
World Jupiter is gigantic and Rocky
Jupiter could retain a lot of internal
heat from when it Formed so even though
it's much further from the Sun than
Earth Rocky Jupiter could have surface
temperatures similar to our planet
it might even have hot oceans
terrestrial Jupiter's gravity might
cause the planet to have a very thick
atmosphere and worlds with thick
atmospheres have yeah High atmospheric
pressure
that means that the boiling point of
water on this Rocky giant would be
higher than it is on Earth than the
oceans could be as hot as 200 degrees
Celsius and still remain liquid
yeah we're not going swimming there
even if you could somehow walk on this
world you wouldn't want to breathe on it
gas giant Jupiter's atmosphere is mostly
hydrogen and helium so if the rocky
Jupiter's atmosphere was also made of
hydrogen and helium
it wouldn't be breathable
then there would be the lightning storms
yeah Jupiter already has massive storms
in its clouds and Rocky Jupiter would be
no different
if this planet also had active volcanoes
spewing Ash and lava well that would
make the lightning storms even more
intense
volcanoes could be good news for the
rocky World though the gases they
release might change the atmosphere of
Rocky Jupiter and make it habitable
and if not for you maybe for some other
life forms and those other life forms
could be terrifying
they might be bigger and stronger than
dinosaurs just to withstand Jupiter's
enormous gravity or they could be tiny
microbes living under Rocky Jupiter's
surface but obviously that's a lot less
exciting
but the thing is Jupiter's increased
gravity would push our planet out of its
stable orbit and that would dramatically
change our climate Earth could be pushed
closer to the Sun turning this place
into a hot hellish world
or we could be driven further from the
Sun and freeze over
either way it's bad news for you
and Earth wouldn't be the only planet
pushed out of its orbit everything in
the solar system would plunge into chaos
planets and moons would be knocked off
course some of them colliding with each
other things would get messy
you could only hope that nothing would
crash into Earth
but you know what things could be worse
like if Jupiter was on a collision
course with us
well that sounds like a story
for another
what if
oh and one more thing we here at what if
are on a mission to reach 10 million
subscribers by the end of the year only
you can help us get there let us show
you the worlds you've never seen before
hit like And subscribe and remember to
tell your friends about us by the way
whoever's left congratulations on
Surviving this episode
[Music]
thank you